should i share the photos now are people
ready for
old maybe slightly embarrassing photos
so i found a lot of photos from
uh from childhood i already started
being like growing facial hair from a
young age
to intimidate my opponents i don't know
where this was taken i think this was
2003 so i was
like nine or ten years old um
this one okay so this one i have a small
story behind this was one of my first
like big chess achievements i was nine
years old
i had just tied for first but i went on
tie breaks
it was a national no it was a state
illinois kindergarten through third
grade state championship
and i got a trophy that was almost as
big as me
yeah hopefully it's it's easy to tell
which person i am between the
four people here yeah this was
um 2003
i was nine my rating at the time i think
was 1200 something
so fun fact uh this person
was recently featured in a chess.com
stream actually a pretty big name in the
crypto space
we both finished with a 7 out of seven
scorer but this is uh
jack mallors who recently had a lesson
with danny wrench on stream
so we were we were friends but also
rivals in childhood
we didn't play each other this
tournament like we both finished with
perfect scores we would have played each
other
if there is an eighth round so moving on
yeah this is a the photo i was happy to
get the first place trophy on tie bricks
i still do have the trophy i believe
it's somewhere in the basement
but not in my current apartment this is
yeah this is a highly
posed photo in front of a trash bin for
some reason
there were no stalemates this tournament
i've i managed to
to win all all the games so the trophy
trophy was almost half my height or more
than half my height
um i guess this is another one
from outside the the venue i was
slightly more
awake in this photo yeah i haven't
really gotten a haircut
since this photo my hair has just stayed
the same length
pretty much ever since uh this is
me at a tournament before starting a
game
oh okay so this is me maybe some people
know who this is
this is a pretty like well-known
public figure in the chess world i did
have a little bit of blonde in my hair
like growing up
yeah my hair like got darker over time
and might might eventually turn white so
i might go back
different end of the spectrum oh good
job to everyone saying
polgar but witch polgar yeah this is uh
susan pogar
we both looked slightly different i
guess i didn't know it at the time but
susan would go on to be my
chess coach in college
because i went to webster university in
2015
and she actually recently retired from
webster saw her a few weeks ago
i did meet judah too i don't think i
have i have a picture with judith
i also met susan's parents which i might
have
photos of this this one i'm just feeding
ducks so i i have a long history with
ducks there is no goose chasing me in
this photo
so thankfully uh i didn't have to
run and fear for my life i mean if you
have food they'll be nice back to you
yes this is papa rosen we were actually
pretty big rivals when i was like seven
and eight years old
the goose were more just kind of
non-rivals more just friends
or what did i say the ducks oh so i
included this photo because this was my
first ever
trip to vegas you can tell the
tournament
it was a north american open 2003.
around new year so beginning of 2004
tournament was held at bally's
and i remember not doing so well but at
least i was able to pose for the photo
it does look like a comfy chair is that
feingold
no oh this is this is me learning
how to try and smile um along with
trophies
this is also maybe 2004 or 2005.
i used to have a basketball short shirt
went through a very brief phase of
playing basketball
yeah the trophy collection gradually
grew over time
actually the the ribbon this red ribbon
was the first ever thing or no
it was this red ribbon the first ever
tournament i played in
i got a ribbon that motivated me to
play some more ah so this is me playing
against susan pogar
she gave a simul yeah i was probably
like 10 or 11 at the time
i'm 27 now so this was over 15 years ago
i remember actually susan crushed me in
this game
it was some queen's gamba decline she
just sacked a piece and then mated me on
the king side
i still have like traumatic memories i'm
pretty sure i still have the scoresheet
somewhere to try and find the game
i don't think this is bill gates but it
might be hard to prove
oh who can name this person grandmaster
strong grandmaster who
sometimes gets mentioned on this stream
yeah this is ray robson before he was a
grandmaster
i think he was like 1900 around this
this time
it's not levy no i remember this game
too i'll have to look for the scoresheet
um but
he crushed me it was something sicilian
he mated me with like
it was queen f1 after like 20 or 30
moves
and i think a few years so if i was
ten or eleven he was probably nine or
ten
so five years after this photo was taken
about he became a grandmaster
i think at the time my rating was like
14 or 1500
oh this is me with another grand master
maybe some people know
the gm there is a tournament in
was it minnesota i think it was
minnesota
it was called the hb global they only
ran it for one year
but there was like a half a million
dollar prize fund
and i actually i won some kind of raffle
giveaway to get a lesson with joel
benjamin
who at the time was probably one of the
top players in the us
and uh he analyzed some of my games
and gave me some lessons or some uh some
insight and tips and advice
i think i have video of this too but uh
yeah we didn't play this was not a
competitive game he was just like
talking and i was listening basically
yeah it looks like i'm frustrating him
but he's just kind of explaining things
he's teaching me yeah this is me taking
down a chess hustler
or being a chess hustler this is taken
not too far away from harvard somewhere
in massachusetts
some kind of square this was back when
people would underestimate me
now people overestimate me i was
probably
11-ish at this point it was me against
another hustler
or was this me and was i the hustler
i should have had a sign that said like
play the future master
i remember losing to this guy actually
i'll share the trap because this guy
actually trapped me with like a basic
sicilian thing
uh i was white opponent played sicilian
played e6 i played like open sicilian
everything
opponent played knight f6 and then
i'm pretty sure actually i can't tell
based on the position but this may have
been
like you can see that black has more
pawns than me so i think that this was
the game
um in this position i played what i
thought was an aggressive
interesting move but it just lost a pawn
for free
yeah i played e5 so why is this a
blunder
some people already know queen h5 is not
a queen a5 and some confusion with
notation but yeah
queen a5 just winning the pawn so
it's one of these traps you you have to
be aware of like when you're white
uh um especially against sicilian when
the queen comes out early
i remember this because it was kind of
traumatic
like imagine being just a young kid
playing
a scary opponent and then getting
trapped after
five moves these photos kind of share
the progression too
of my my chest development
so i was a bit older here maybe 12-ish
years old
um i'm sure some people would recognize
this face
this is former us champion yuri shulman
who actually
was my coach for um
different stages of my like later chess
career
coached me a bit in college and then
also
in high school i attended many of his
camps
and he played the simula against
probably like a few dozen people
and i managed to manage to draw him
final position
insufficient mating material so um
yeah he was very influential in my uh my
chest development
this is me this was back when cameras
suffered with like
red eye wrapping the old navy brand
i used to wear a hat i guess this was in
california
yeah some some older slightly more
outdated fashion
ah so i shared the photo earlier so this
is like 2004
or 2005 and this is 2010.
this was at the u.s junior championship
in st louis
so this game uh st louis chess club was
doing commentary
ben feingold jen shahadi and i believe
hikaru
were commentating at least the early
rounds of this tournament
um but this was before the st louis
chess club youtube channel so the
the archive i don't think was saved
like i did ask the club to track it down
and like it might be on a hard drive
somewhere but
uh it'd be cool to find the coverage of
uh
especially this game it was a really
hard-fought game that ended in the draw
and then on the rest day of the
tournament they hosted
a block party it was a chess club
two-year anniversary
and they had like the street closed down
and they invited
nfl linebacker lawrence moroney to play
tennis with us on the street and they
set up like this
tennis impromptu thing and then in the
background they're playing chess
but there was a tennis net on the
chessboard as well
um and then we we were actually playing
against ben
feingold and lindsey davenport who's a
former
world number one women's tennis player
um i think there's more photos online
somewhere
but it was a cool experience oh and then
this is at the closing ceremony of the
tournament
uh there were chessboards i guess i was
wearing a slightly oversized suit
and then in the background it's just
takaru chilling
looking happy we're getting to the point
where i'm not really a
baby anymore even though so this photo
was
about 10 years ago this was probably the
most important chess game i ever played
last round of the high school nationals
i had six out of six and i played
i think i am at the time mark arnold and
i managed to win
and then i won i won the tournament
got a national title uh
qualified for the world championships in
brazil
good memories i played the english
opening this was before i knew how to
play the english opening
but i played it anyway because i just
tried to avoid all opening theory
and then got a position where my rook
somehow jumped to f5
and black was underdeveloped this is
also back when
before they had like a digital broadcast
they just had the demo board
and then people like crowded around to
watch so slightly more intense
oh yeah chad i think was there chad is
probably somewhere lurking
oh and then this so jumping forward
this was at the world championship it
was a world u18 championship in brazil
i was on board one in the second to last
round
i was playing the top seed uh grand
master from armenia
and i gave him a hat this is a chicago
chicago blaze it was a uf chess league
hat
anyway if i won this game which i i
got completely outplayed but if i won i
would have had like a decent chance
of winning the the u18 world
championship i think
in the end i finished in ninth and this
is the tournament i got my
first im norm and unlike the previous
tournament i showed we were playing on
on digital boards so
there there was a live broadcast online
at what age did you reach i am
oh rhino had the same question i became
an i am
at 20.
so i fulfilled all the requirements of
20 but that my title got approved
when i was 21 this was back in 2015
wait 2015 yeah 2015. oh this is a good
friend of mine this was a
teammate when i attended university of
illinois um
chess master playing chess in new york
with people watching
through the window on a rainy day just a
funny photo
i became a national master in 2009 which
is actually that was very good timing
this is the last round of the us open
2009 after this tournament i crossed the
2200
rating i defeated uh john fedorwicz
in 16 moves with black it was pretty
memorable
i've shown this game a few times on
stream
videos on my youtube channel oh this is
me attempting to feed a goat
but slightly failing i don't know why
i chose to include this photo oh this is
me and magnus this is 2015.
my first week at webster university
magnus just visited
and played soccer with us this is me
i don't know which photo is more
valuable me and magnus or me and
kangaroo chess match this was 2017
december 2017 oh oh this is a video
aha this is a video
of me playing ping pong
i'm curious if anyone can identify this
person it's not santa claus
so there's a book let me let me give
some back story there's a book
um it's like a giant book of over 5 000
chess positions it's by um
lazlo polgar so the father of of judith
susan and sophia so this is me playing
ping pong
against a pretty legendary figure in the
chess world
and it's a pretty good ping-pong player
we were playing playing at webster i
think back in 20
2019 2020.
so this is a very short clip i think it
was ray robson actually taking
doing the filming i
i think we were just playing casually
just for fun
[Music]
but i have some like old footage of me
like reading
his his book uh this this chess puzzle
book
so it's kind of cool to reflect
on the fact like read the book and then
eventually get to play ping-pong against
author
yeah that's that's the chess oh there's
one more oh it's me and fabiano
yeah this was this was 2019 there's a
rapid tournament
in san francisco but we didn't play each
other he just sat across from me because
he got confused